that a young woman has lost her life and
that her family is grieving
mr speaker let me turn to this weekend's
events
i have already said that some of the
footage circulating
online of clapham common is upsetting
so whilst the police are rightly
operationally independent
i asked the metropolitan police for a
report into what had happened
this government backs our place in
fighting crime and keeping the public
safe
but in the interests of providing
greater assurance
and ensuring public confidence i have
asked her majesty's inspectorate of
constabulary
to conduct a full independent lessons
learned review
the metropolitan police commissioner has
welcomed this and i will await the
report
and of course update the house in due
course
mr speaker i would like to take a moment
to acknowledge why sarah's death has
upset so many
my heartache and that of others can be
summed up
in just five words she was just walking
home
and while the specific circumstances of
sarah's disappearance are thankfully
uncommon
what has happened has reminded women
everywhere
of the steps that we take each day
without a second thought to keep
ourselves safe
it has rightly ignited anger at the
danger posed to women by predatory men
and anger i feel as strongly as anyone
and accounts shared online in the wake
of sarah's disappearance
are so powerful because every single one
of us
can relate to them too many of us have
walked home
from school or work alone only to hear
footsteps uncomfortably close behind us
too many of us have pretended to be on
the phone to a friend
to scare someone off too many of us
have clutched our keys and our fists in
case we need to defend ourselves
and that is not okay women and girls
must feel safe whilst walking our
streets
that is why we have continued to take
action
our landmark domestic abuse bill is on
track to receive royal assent by the end
of april
and this will transform our collective
response
to this abort crime this builds on other
measures we have brought forward
including the controlling or coercive
behaviour offense
and the domestic violence disclosure
scheme known as claire's law
which enables individuals to ask the
police whether their partner has a
violent or abusive past
we have also introduced new preventative
tools
and powers to tackle crimes including
stalking
female genital mutilation and so-called
up skirting
but we can never be complacent which is
why throughout the passage of the
domestic abuse bill
we have accepted amendments from
honourable members
from political parties across this house
the bill now includes new offenses of
non-fatal strangulation
outlaws threats to disclose intimate
images
and extends the control in our host
coercive behavior offence
to cover post-separation abuse
this is in addition to the bill's
existing measures which include a new
statutory definition of domestic abuse
that recognises the many forms abuse can
take
that's psychological physical
emotional economic sexual
and of course the impact of abuse on
children
as well as the new rules to prevent
victims having to go through the pain of
being cross-examined by their abusers
in family and in civil courts
we all know action is needed to improve
the outcomes for rape cases
and we are currently developing robust
actions as part of our end-to-end
review of rape to reverse the decline in
outcomes in recent years
and mr speaker at the end of last year
in december
i launched the first ever public survey
of women and girls
to hear their views on how we can better
tackle these gendered crimes
on friday in the wake of the outpouring
of grief
i reopened that survey i can tell the
house that as of 11am today
the home office has received 78 000
responses since 6 pm
on friday that is completely
unprecedented
and considerably more than the 18 000
responses received over the entire
10-week period
when the survey was previously open
i'm listening to women and girls up and
down the country
and their views will help to shape a new
strategy on tackling violence against
women and girls
which i will bring forward to this house
later this year
the police crime sentencing and courts
bill which
we will mr speaker shortly be debating
will end the halfway release of those
convicted for sexual offences such as
rape
instead under our law vile criminals
responsible for these terrible crimes
will spend at least two thirds of their
time behind
bars our new law will extend the scope
of the sexual offences act 2003
with regards to the abuse of positions
of trust something which predominantly
affects young girls
and it will introduce kay's law which
will encourage the police to impose
pre-charge bail
with appropriate conditions where
necessary and proportionate to do so
which we hope will will provide
reassurance and additional protection
for alleged victims in high harm cases
like domestic abuse
i know the opposition will today be
voting against these crucial measures
against measures to support victims of
violent crimes including young women and
girls
finally mr speaker the government is
providing an extra 40 million pounds to
help victims during the pandemic and
beyond
and last month we launched a new
government advertising campaign
it still matters to raise awareness of
sexual violence services
and ensure victims know where to get
help
mr speaker i want to end by saying that
over the past year
during the coronavirus pandemic the
police have been faced with an
unenviable and immediately difficult
task
it is one for most part that they have
approached with skill and
professionalism
helping to enforce regulations as
determined by parliament
with one crucial objective in mind to
save lives
this house approved those changes by 524
votes to 16 on the 6th of january this
year
sadly as of sunday the 14th of march
more than 125
500 lives have been lost to this
horrible virus
it is for that reason that i continue to
urge everyone for as long as these
regulations are in place
not to participate in large gatherings
or attend protests
the right to protest is the cornerstone
of our democracy
but the government's duty remains to
prevent more lives being lost during
this pandemic
finally mr speaker there will
undoubtedly be more discussions of these
vitally important issues
in the days and weeks to come but we
cannot forget
i must not forget that a family is
grieving and i know the thoughts and
prayers of this whole
house are with sarah's loved ones at
this truly terrible time
we now come to shadow home secretary
nick thomason
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
home secretary for coming to the house
today
to make a statement for advanced site of
it
we come together at a time of national
grief and what would now be
a time of change the news of sarah
everard's death is heartbreaking
for us all and our thoughts are with her
family and friends
and whilst i of course appreciate the
legal sensitivity of the case
reports around its circumstances are
extremely distressing
the reaction to sarah everard's death
across the country
has been extraordinarily powerful and
moving led by the passionate voices
of women and girls who are rightly
demanding action
and change and it cannot be right that
so many women
continue to fear for their safety on a
daily basis
whether on the streets or at home the
testimonies that have been shared
highlight the unacceptable levels of
abuse
and misogyny harassment on the streets
walking home with headphones turned off
to listen for threats
keys between fingers being told to stay
home after dark to avoid attackers but
let me be clear
it is not women who should change their
behavior it is men
and wider society that needs to change
and at times like this
it is vital people are able to have
their voices heard
of course in a way that is lawful and
coveted secure
yet this weekend in clapham things
clearly went very wrong
and i share the anger about the policing
and the scenes we saw
it's right that the mayor of london has
shown leadership
by calling on her magistrate majesty's
inspectorate of constabulary
and the independent office for police
conduct to investigate
the home secretary asked for a report
from the commissioner of the
metropolitan police
i hope she will publish it because
transparency is so important
can the home secretary also publish the
minutes of the advanced meeting that
were held on friday
mentioned by the policing minister on
the media this morning
and can she confirm what communication
she personally had
with the metropolitan police prior to
the events on saturday
and whilst the event was a vigil not a
protest
the scenes from clapham should be a red
warning light to the government that
ministers should not be rushing through
laws cracking down on protest
the truth is mr speaker this government
is
failing to address violence against
women and girls
and ministers even want to curtail their
right to protest about it
it is a chronic failure from this
government
a meetings and reopening surveys alone
are nowhere near enough and meetings we
understand
that the women and equalities minister
won't even be attending this evening
figures from the office for national
statistics show that recorded rapes
doubled between 2014 and 2019
doubled the crime survey for england and
wales
showed that over 2 million people
experienced domestic abuse in a year
yet only a tiny fraction are charged and
charging rates are falling
the justice system sends a perverse
message
that murdering someone at home which
predominantly means
men killing women is a lesser crime than
killing someone in the street
by handing out shorter sentences for
domestic homicides
the 296 page bill
we will consider later today contains
the word memorial
eight times and fails to include the
word women
once the government's message is they
want
to lock up people who damage the statues
of slave traders for 10 years
when rape sentences start at half that
and i say to the government today unless
this changes unless there's action on
homicide
unless there's action on street
harassment unless there's action on
stalking
this bill will risk becoming an abuser's
charter
that just allows violence and injustice
in our streets in our homes to continue
unchecked
ministers have been on the airwaves
today struggling to find aspects of the
bill
that will make a difference to
addressing violence against women and
girls
and let me just take one example
ministers have
pointed to whole life terrorists for
rape
now i would ask the home secretary when
she gets to her feet
to answer how many rape convictions have
resulted in life terms
because the answer is hardly any today
the high court ruled
in favor of the status quo on rape and
it is a status quo that
is shameful and the government must
change
the figures show that 99
99 of rapes reported to the police in
england and wales
result in no legal proceedings
whatsoever
99 it's effectively a get out of jail
free card and it is appalling
it doesn't have to be this way this
could be
a time of national unity when we decide
to come together as a country to put
forward protections the government can
either change course
take necessary action or ministers will
find themselves
on the wrong side of history once again
secretary thank you mr speaker um i'd
like to thank the honourable gentleman
for his comments but if i may mr speaker
at a time when the country is
mourning insignificant a significant
loss
and there there are moments of great
unity
i'm quite sorry to hear the tone of the
honourable gentleman particularly in
term of the
government's record when it comes to and
our commitment of tackling violence
against women and girls
and the right honourable gentleman will
also be well cited
more than aware of the significant
contributions
of all members of this house to the
domestic abuse bill
which has been under debate scrutiny
challenge amendment for a considerable
period of time in fact
and it is in the house of lords the
other place right now
but i would like to emphasize mr speaker
that this government is committed when
it comes to violence against women and
girls at the highest level
and when you look at in fact the work of
this government over the last decade and
if i may
mr speaker i'd like to pay tribute to my
right humble friend the
member for maidenhead for all her work
in particular because she was the one
that really set the bar high
in legislation from all the measures not
just in terms of the d.a bill but
fgm violence against women and girls
everything that has been put forward in
terms of money support for charities
this government is building upon that
and no one can ignore
that simple fact the right humble
gentleman
has also made some specific references
to the bill that will be debated this
afternoon
um in particular as well to rape and
rape convictions
the bill is a criminal um criminal
justice bill as well as a policing bill
and he will also be very mindful of the
work that this government is undertaking
right now
with regards to the end-to-end rape
review to completely
reverse the declining outcomes that we
have seen in recent years this
government is increasingly and very
honest up front about
the declining outcomes that we have seen
we are working with
all the relevant parties including the
cps
we want to change the way of direction
there
and there is much more work to come and
that will be published in due course
shortly in fact
but to say that the bill itself does
nothing for women
is completely wrong primarily when it
comes to sentencing because it'll end
the halfway release of those convicted
for sexual offenses such as rape
instead our laws will go after those
vile criminals and they will spend at
least two thirds of their times behind
bars
and mr speaker i think it's worth
reflecting that it was in 2003 under a
labor government that made automatic
halfway release mandatory
for all standard determinants sentences
regardless of whether the offender has
been convicted of a violent or sexual
offence and the bill discussion that
will be debated later on will reverse
that policy
the honorable gentleman the right
honourable gentleman also says that
there's no mention of women
in the bill specifically that's another
accusation that i will
reject primarily because it's a criminal
law and sentencing bill
which applies equally to everybody and
the party opposite will also know
that in line with the serious organized
crime and police act bill in 2005 the
criminal justice act
in 2003 neither of those bills which
related to criminal justice and
sentencing
mentioned women as well now of course
there are many other measures that we
will discuss
through the passage later on of this
bill but i do mr speaker want to come
back to
the statement the points that i have
made in particular
it is right when it comes to the
metropolitan
police i have had many discussions with
them on friday
over the weekend with the commissioner
specifically
in relation to preparations and planning
prior to saturday evening
my comments are public they're on the
record in terms of what has happened
and quite frankly the upsetting images
that were
um out on saturday evening we have a
review that's now
being conducted by her majesty's
inspectorate of contemporary
it is right that takes place i also
think mr speaker no one should pre-judge
anything in terms of you know conduct um
until we absolutely see what has
happened in terms of that report the
police are rightly operationally
independent
but i do just want to conclude by saying
that of course all of us in this house
this isn't just about the government
all of us want to work to drive the
right outcomes so that women feel safe
laws and legislation will absolutely do
that there's no question about that
but there is something also about
behavior and culture
that's culture across society that's
culture with men
as well and we should be upfront about
that never shy away from
being honest and discussing that but
right now
i think this house should all have in
their thoughts and in their prayer
sarah's families and friends at this
particularly unbearable time
to write or will theresa may thank you
mr speaker and i thank my right
honourable friend for her remarks
and she's right to remind us that behind
the events of saturday
lies the tragic death of sarah everard a
bright young woman
dearly loved by her family and friends
and i join my right honourable friend
and other members of this house
in saying that my thoughts and prayers
are with sarah's family and friends at
this time
we want justice for sarah we also want
women to be able to feel and be
safe on our streets and in their homes
so does my right honourable friend agree
that we must redouble our efforts
to make sure that the government's
excellent domestic abuse bill reaches
the statute book
as anticipated next month but also
recognize that legislation is not enough
and that if we are going to eradicate
violence against women and girls
we need a change of attitudes and that
is about dealing with perpetrators
changing their behavior
but also teaching young men and boys
about respect
for women and about what is or is not
acceptable in a relationship
i i would just like to very much pay
tribute to my right honourable friend
for her comments
and her work and leadership no question
um around domestic abuse but violence
against women and girls
and she's absolutely right in terms of
the fact that
the domestic abuse bill is a landmark
bill it is a landmark piece of
legislation
that i think actually all honourable
members of this house should feel proud
of in the work that has come together
across across this house um but also
my writing friend is absolutely right in
terms of the cultural
and behavioral aspects that must be
changed
and you know for all all of us have to
be
conscious of that you know as as a
mother bringing up a
young son um absolutely respecting
women and girls and treating everyone
fairly
and rightly with equality and
understanding that
there are no barriers in demonstrating
that respect to one another
and importantly tolerance to one another
as well is absolutely vital
there is so much more work to do
legislation can only go
so far we can never ever be complacent
but with that as well as a government
and i think this parliament this house
across both houses will absolutely share
the determination
and the desire to do so much more when
it comes to protecting
girls and women but also in our
strategies where we must all be united
this isn't about just saying you know um
there's a survey taking place we must
all contribute to that and in fact now
the survey has been reopened
i very much hope that members of the
party opposite will actually contribute
to that
to help us have a united and coherent
approach
one voice approach in fact to how we can
support and prevent
um support women and girls but prevent
violence against women and girls too
let's go to smp spokesperson angela
crawley angela
thank you mr speaker the murder of sarah
everard has truly shocked and saddened
us
all can i join the other others in
sending our heartfelt condolences to
sarah's family
and friends at this time she was walking
home
a sentence that resonates with all women
this tragedy
serves as a stark reminder to women who
assess
every aspect of their daily lives in
fear of sexual violence
assault or abhorrent crimes inflicted at
the hands of men
can i once more take this opportunity to
urge the pm
to ratify this and build convention
without further delay
across the uk this weekend women reclaim
the streets
in protest and to pay tribute to the
life of sarah everard
police responding have received
widespread criticism and the questions
must be answered
as to whether the actions were necessary
and proportionate
to protect and prevent public harm the
public health crisis has made
restrictions necessary and the problem
rings unadvisable so while the police
face difficult decisions every day
it's impossible to watch the footage of
the events at clapham comes
without shock and concern that the
policing appeared heavy-handed and
disproportionate
therefore it is right that the chief
inspector constabulary
has been asked to conduct a review in
scotland this incident would have been
examined by the independent advisory
group
experts with a specific remit to ensure
the use of powers is consistent with
human rights
principles and legislation turning to
the police
sentencing and court bill the right of
protest must remain a
fundamental human right can i therefore
ask the secretary of state
to confirm that the remit of the chief
inspector's review will focus on human
rights as well as policing matters
i thank the honourable lady for her
remarks and also her sentiment
um on the tragic death of sarah everard
i think there are a number of points um
that i if i may just come back on to
i mean the honourable lady is absolutely
right in terms of the role of the
inspectorate and we will wait for that
review and obviously i will report back
and i think it's worth just reflecting
mr speaker once again
that this has been a difficult and
demanding
period for the police um the impact of
coronavirus restrictions and we know
why they are in place as well and on the
point of protest mr speaker i'm very
very conscious that we will have the
debate later on this afternoon as well
this government absolutely supports um
the assembly the freedom of expression
and clearly when it comes to the whole
issue of the right to protest that's
fundamental to our democratic freedoms
without wanting to prejudge the debate
or prejudge the further
um discussions on the bill the
legislation
will of course speak about the police
using
um powers in terms of how they would
manage protests
but it's also worth reflecting that this
will be updating legislation
um the public order act of 1986 which
was enacted
over 30 years ago and so this will be
very much part of the discussion that
we'll be having in due course let's go
to deanna davison
diana thank you mr speaker
and i joined my right-hand girlfriend
and voices right across the house and
paying my deepest condolences to
sarah everard's family and loved ones
it's a truly
heartbreaking situation that i know has
allowed many women to find the strength
to share their own experiences
and i was really moved to hear that 78
000 people have now responded
to the reopened consultation and i'm
encouraging many others to do the same
and share their voice
but does my white normal friend agree
with me that if we really want to get
the best outcome
and make our streets feel safer for
everyone that we have to listen to all
voices both men and women
people of all political persuasions to
ensure that we're truly working together
to deliver the change that we need
i'm secretary well i thank my honorable
friend for her
her comments and her questions actually
as well she's of course absolutely right
and you know this is a collective effort
for
everyone to be part of shaping futures
strategy
shaping future policy and legislation
and we can do that together
which is why mr speaker it is quite
unprecedented and incredible that
78 000 people have responded to
the survey that is something we are we
are really pleased about because we do
want to encourage people to contribute
and i would also encourage as you've
already heard me say mr speaker
all members of this house to play their
role and actually join that contribution
slight committee mr speaker can i join
with
the expressions from across the house of
deep
sympathy and condolences to sarah
everard's family
following her tragic death women across
the country have
been moved to talk about the experiences
that we all share and that no one should
have to endure feeling threatened
and unsafe on our own streets eight
months ago
i put forward measures to a deal with
repeat perpetrators of abuse and
stalking
to be able to register them to be able
to prevent the problem where
they move from one victim to another no
one keeps track
and they get away with it at that time
ministers said those measures weren't
needed
has she looked at this again and will
she work with me and baroness royal and
paladin
to make sure we can bring in these
strong measures and take action against
repeat perpetrators
and keep more women safe the right
honourable lady is absolutely right
about the points that she has been
raising and the measures
um at large there is something
about perpetrators and their serial
offending that has to be addressed there
is no
question about that at all and of course
this does link
predominantly to many of the criminal
justice outcomes and
the wider debate that this house will be
having not just later on today but i
but over future weeks as well i will be
very candid we will look at all measures
and rightly so
we should be doing everything possible
to keep women safe
but actually keeping everyone safe and
the behavior of serial perpetrator
serial offenders
is deeply corrosive deeply damaging and
obviously
with just dreadful dreadful implications
and consequences
so we'd be very happy to continue not
just to
look at these measures but i think it's
fair to say right now obviously with the
violence against women and girls
consultation that is underway
we will continue to engage with others
and follow up on these points
let's go to philip davies philip dennis
thank you mr speaker it's clearly
unacceptable for
any woman to feel unsafe walking the
streets can i propose some
practical measures that the home
secretary might adopt
can she introduce a fund to roll out
much more cctv
around the country which will help to
make our streets safer for people and
bring
evidence where there's a crime committed
can't you stop taking people off the dna
database there are huge numbers of
crimes
sexual assaults rapes and murders where
there's dna evidence
available but no match and the more
people on the dna database the more
chance of getting these people
off our streets and rightly convicted
can we increase the sentences for people
convicted of sexual assaults
and rapes and can we stop the early
release the automatic early release
of criminals who still are considered a
threat to society these measures would
actually help
make our streets safer for everyone
thank you mr speaker um and i thank my
honourable friend for his
his comments and his practical
suggestions we are doing a lot on cctv
and we do have the safer streets fund
which
my old friend will be very very aware of
and of course he's raised a number of
areas which i suspect if he were to join
the bill committee of the police crime
sentencing and courts bill
he could absolutely contribute to and
make those points there
thank you mr speaker and i'm joined
members
in continuing to extend our thoughts and
prayers to sarah everard's family
my constituents have reacted with
justified anger to the metropolitan
police's treatment
of those in attendance at this weekend's
vigil to commemorate sarah
and all women who lost their lives to
gender-based violence
it's bitterly ironic that an event
intended to highlight the issue of
public safety for women
was blocked on the grounds of public
safety what happened this weekend is a
reminder
of what happens when police try to
completely bypass the views of the
communities they serve
so does the home secretary recognize
that the police's high-handed approach
got the balance between public safety
and the right to protest completely
wrong does the home secretary agree
that the police's heavy-handed treatment
of female protesters
was wrong and will the home secretary
now accept her policing crime and
sentencing and court spill
is ill-conceived my constituents are
very angry about what was
what has happened and want to know what
the government will do
to reassure them that they will
proactively address violence against
women and girls
and deep-seated forms of institutional
discrimination in the uk police
thank you mr speaker um well i
understand the sentiment that the
onboard lady
is raising on behalf of her constituents
and obviously recognize the constituency
that she represents and the
terrible um tragic events that have
happened and taken place
all our thoughts are clearly with sarah
everard and her family and of course
the vigil that was planned the police
themselves and metropolitan police had
been involved and spent a great deal of
time
with the organizers and the metropolitan
police have been very public about that
i'm not going to repeat my comments
about seeking greater assurance
and ensuring public confidence in
policing hence the reason why her
majesty's inspectorate
are now conducting a full independent
lessons learned review i think that is
absolutely appropriate my comments about
saturday evening are on the record
and well known with regards to the
police
crime sentencing and courts bill which
the unborn lady has referred to
that is a manifesto bill that this
government was elected on and
we will of course participate in second
reading later on this afternoon
it is not ill conceived at all british
public voted for it
we live in a democracy and this
government will work to deliver on that
let's go to pauline latham pauline
thank you mr speaker can i welcome the
announced in-depth review
into the criminal justice system when it
comes to rape and sexual assault
does my russian girlfriend agree that
every part of the
criminal justice system has to play its
role
in bringing perpetrators to justice and
better supporting victims
there's a lot of rape happens within
marriage
and it's not the best situation when
people have been married
under the age of 18 to a man who is much
older
so could my right honourable friend also
look at that
to see how we can stop that sort of
situation
arising my friend is absolutely right
and i just would like to pay tribute to
her for her work and campaigning
um on this particular issue um and of
course she's absolutely right that this
is
about the criminal justice system from
an end-to-end perspective so from
policing
right through not just to charging but
actually conviction as well
and that is effectively what the police
bill is about the police crime
sentencing and courts bill which is why
it goes across two departments
but the rape review itself is
fundamentally important because
obviously
the numbers have not been going in the
right direction we have to understand
the lessons
as to why charging decisions have been
you know how they are
also the impact on witnesses and victims
themselves
victims and the attrition that takes
place when it comes to them even going
to court
so there is a lot of work that's taken
place in this area i should also just
mention in dispatches the
prime minister leads the crime and
justice task force where this is one of
those fundamental issues
again across government not just home
office but across the moj where we are
bringing these core elements together
with the dpp looking working with the
cps working with the aeg
these issues are absolutely integral to
the entire system
let's go to ed david and davey
can i send my condolences and thoughts
to the family and friends of sarah
everard at this most difficult of times
mr speaker the scenes of women being
forced to the ground restrained
and arrested simply for holding a
peaceful
vigil in memory of sarah everard
and in condemnation of violence against
women and girls
were utterly disgraceful
of course the met commissioner chris
dick must resign
but can i ask the home secretary
what personal responsibility she herself
has
for the terrible handling of this
peaceful vigil
did the home secretary speak to the met
commissioner
in the run-up to the vigil if so
will she tell the house now what
guidance
and advice she gave the met police
in advance of the vigil
mr speaker the honorable gentleman is
right in the sense that those scenes
were distressing
and upsetting there is no question about
that at all
and i've already spoken about the
measures that are now in place
in terms of getting assurance on in the
way in which
the metropolitan police conducted
obviously their operations they're
rightly operationally independent
and there is obviously now the lessons
learned independent review taking place
i had been in touch with the
metropolitan police commissioner
on friday and throughout the weekend and
we have had extensive discussions
in terms of planning preparation for the
vigil at the weekend
i should however mr speaker emphasize
that on friday there was legal action
underway so until that legal action
heard being determined um and of course
metropolitan police
the commissioner and the met police
themselves were engaging with the
organizers of the visual
there were various plans that the police
were working on
i will be very clear though on friday my
views were known
and they were based on the fact that
people
who wanted to pay tribute obviously
within the locality
bear in mind we are in a pandemic we
cannot forget that we are in a health
pandemic
that people who live locally clearly who
who were either out you know on a daily
basis
passing through laying flowers is
absolutely the right thing to do and we
saw many people doing that
but of course as i've said those scenes
on saturday evening were upsetting
that is the reason why i asked for the
metropolitan police commissioner to
provide a report on the event itself
what happened and now why we have a
lessons learned review
into the operational um effect and
impact in terms of what happened
pretty patel they're giving evidence to
the house of commons following
the scenes on saturday evening at the
vigil
following the death of sarah everard the
vigil taking place at clapham common
she's also been asked questions about
the police crimes sentencing and
courts bill nick thomas simmons the
shadow home secretary
saying that statues are mentioned in the
bill 10 times no
mention of the word women
and ed davey reiterating his call for
cressida dick to
resign and asking questions about what
the home secretary
said to the met police commissioner in
the run-up
to that vigil and what advice she gave
she reminded the comments that we are in
the middle
of a pandemic we're going to return to
the commons
shortly but we're just going to take us
a pause to bring you
an update on some breaking news and
france germany and
italy have now joined the eu countries
to suspend
the roll out of the oxford astrazeneca
covid vaccine the head of the oxford
vaccine group
has reassured the public over its use
following reports of serious blood
clotting
in four patients in norway the french
president emmanuel macron
has said the european watchdog will
issue a ruling on the oxford jab
tomorrow hassan's correspondent thomas
moore joins me now
that list of countries suspending the
use of the vaccine for now getting
longer
thomas what's happening
which around a dozen countries around
the world that have suspended the
vaccine
or suspended certain batches of the
vaccine
and it does all boil down to this link
with blood clots
now there have been a number of people
who have suffered blood clots deep veins
from boces and also
clots in the lung after they've been
vaccinated and there have been
some of those that have died now
what isn't clear though that these were
actually caused by the vaccine and
that's why the european
medicines agency is looking at the
evidence it does seem to be
coming down to the statistics at the
moment and the
ema has said that so far out of 5
million people to have had the vaccine
across the continent there have been
30 reports of blood clots now in a
population of that size
you'd expect one in a thousand or around
100 a week developing a blood clot even
without
vaccination so you can see why many
experts will say well there just isn't
any evidence that it is the vaccine
that is causing this that it could be
many other reasons other medical
conditions
that people would naturally have and
just because there is this temporal
association with vaccination doesn't
mean that the vaccine caused it and it's
only the world
health organization is extremely
concerned that there is a bit of a
bandwagon now that people are
countries are pausing their vaccinations
uh waiting to see what happens when in
fact people are dying from covid
every day so this theoretical link is
leading to
people giving up on a vaccine which has
a known beneficial
effect so the prime minister also in the
uk has said that there's
no evidence to be concerned about here
in the uk that the rollout here in the
uk will continue
that every confidence in the safety and
the effect
of the astrazeneca vaccine
through protest as well manage protests
in the right way
and the police always engage with
individuals and organizers
we will debate this during the course of
the bill mr speaker
but i'm afraid i think the honourable
lady has completely misrepresented the
proposals that we are putting forward
sharian duncan smith mr speaker uh the
murder of sarah rod is was a shocking
event and i
feel terribly sorry for the family and
they've gone through made even edgier
really by the fact that there's now been
charges leveled against a police officer
we
require police officers to protect
everybody particularly and women as well
however i received a note from a police
or
other current distributors antoine we
shouldn't be talking about the suspect
at this stage
uh i'm honestly speaking i wasn't going
to refer to you other than justin
parsley
uh the reality though that the writer of
my writing friend has announced that she
is having an inquiry into what happened
in those
terrible events on saturday night and
they were shameful
but it ill behold politicians to get up
pass judgment on what happened without
all the evidence
i was contacted by a female police
officer today
to tell me of what happened to her on
that night she was threatened
she was told that she should have been
murdered not sarah everard
and that she was manhandled i simply say
on all sides
we should be dialing this down not
trying to raise the temperature by
calling
for resignations etc well can i just
thank my right honourable friend for his
remarks his comment and the point that
he makes
and it's a well made point if i may say
so
i too mr speaker been written to by many
police officers
expressing very similar sentiments as
well from their own
experiences and i think the point about
not prejudging is absolutely
right the police have operational
independence
obviously as home secretary i have
called for a report i've received a
report but there is now an
independent review and it's right that
we have that review
yes for assurance purposes but also to
strengthen public confidence in policing
and obviously for all members of this
house as well
to in due course hear the full facts as
to what happened
let's go to the several roberts liz
diacon bolivares and i would like to
take this opportunity to extend my
personal fat sympathy
for the family and friends of sarah
abraham this horrific time
in june 2020 i proposed a domestic abuse
register for the early identification of
abuse of men
as a means of preventing death and
injury the minister for safeguarding
guarding rejected this claiming that
current systems for preventing violence
violence against women were adequate the
national police chief's council
also objected on the grounds of costs
and their capacity to manage such a
register
i sense that the government now
recognizes that the current system is
failing women
and that a properly funded staffed and
supported register for serial stalkers
and domestic violence perpetrators is
urgently needed
how will the home secretary make sure
that such new proposals and funding
properly account for the different
legislative landscape in wales
so that women in wales aren't excluded
from future protections
which i hope are on their way
mr speaker i think this is an important
important moment actually
for this house and for colleagues when
it comes to domestic abuse bill
measures which have been extensively
debated in this house
it is vital of course and the right
honourable lady has
clearly spoken about wales and the
authority and the responsibilities there
we are absolutely working across the
devolved administrations because we want
consistency in the approach it's right
that we all work together
to support women and the domestic abuser
will do that
absolutely do that and my honorable
friend the safeguarding minister has
worked extensively with all colleagues
in the house
on the issue that the honourable lady
has raised but the fact of the matter is
we want this bill to receive royal
assent it should do
very soon we need it to happen to
safeguard more and more
women and give the protection that they
desperately need from their from their
abusers
chris loader thank you mr speaker i went
to clapham common bandstand yesterday
evening to pay my own respects
and i like members from across this
house uh send my greatest sympathies and
services to
sarah's family mr speaker i believe that
it is highly regrettable
that members of the opposition demand
that the first
female commissioner of the metropolitan
police resign
in this situation may i ask my right
honourable friend
what is she doing to ensure that the
facts are understood properly
before premature conclusions are made on
people's
actions thank you well i thank my
friend for his question and also for the
sentiment that he has shared with the
house this afternoon
i agree entirely with his comments and
alongside that of course he has asked
what
what i'm what am i doing by
commissioning the
inspectorate of constabulary it is
important that we have the full facts
in addition to supplement the lessons
learned review
and i i come back to the point mr
speaker
i would really strongly recommend that
colleagues do not
pre-judge the images were upsetting of
course they were upsetting
but alongside that it is right that we
see the full report in due course and
we hear the facts as they come out
will you know country and paisley uh
thank you uh mr speaker
can i tell you add my voice uh and
condolences
to the family of uh ms average
and her family and friends and all those
who have been affected by this most
hellish
and uh murders turning to the events
that we saw in clapham common
on saturday evening mr speaker
members i think are entitled to ask the
question however
what on earth were the metropolitan
police thinking
what on earth happened to police
discretion
what on earth happened to
proportionality
to flexibility to empathy
to any sense of self-awareness giving
the circumstances that surrounded
that hellish murder every ingredient of
good policing
in my view and the views of many of my
constituents
appeared to be completely absent from
the policing
activity on clapham common the defining
image that will stick
in the collective mind of britain will
be patsy stevenson
being almost sat upon by three police
officers
whilst being detained i must say modern
deputy speaker if i saw one of my adult
daughters
treated that way i would find it
impossible
to contain my anger in terms of what
happened can i ask the home secretary
therefore
how quickly will this report be made
available
how expeditiously can the home secretary
act
to rectify what is an appalling wrong
secretary thank you madam deputy speaker
um the honourable gentleman's comments
are
very strong but in response to his
question
he knows that the house knows i've um uh
commissioned now the cons
inspectorate of constabulary for the
report
i have asked for the report to conclude
in the next fortnight
um which we will then obviously then
update the house
in terms of findings and recommendations
i think
madame deputy speaker it's worth just
reflecting though in terms of what
happened on saturday for approximately
eight hours
there was peace around the bandstand
people were respectfully well paying
their respects
laying flowers grieving showing support
and empathy
in a way in which you know every
individual
would want to in terms of offering their
sympathies and condolences
that is why we need to look at the
review to see
effectively what happened operationally
and then of course
if lessons need to be learned they will
be post a report
sarah died thank you madam deputy
speaker may i offer also my condolences
to the friends and family of sarah
everard
does my autonomous friend agree with me
that it's frankly absurd to hear this
afternoon that the party opposite
is actually opposing the provisions of
the police crime sentencing and court
spill
that wants to increase sentences for
rapists there's a dichotomy there which
is a bit absurd is it not
secretary well my befriend is absolutely
right and to be very frank madam deputy
speaker
i i was quite surprised when i did hear
that was the position that the party
opposite
were taking place this is a criminal
justice bill
it will increase sentences for
individuals perpetrators that perpetrate
the most
horrendous appalling sexual offenses and
crimes against women children
citizens and of course it is an
important bill as i've said already
madam deputy speakers
key to our manifesto british public
voted for it
this government and our party and
government as well are absolutely
determined
to strengthen our laws and the criminal
justice system
so that we can pull away those
individuals that cause harm to
individuals
and increase sentences we now go to
diane
abbott
our thoughts and prayers are with sarah
everard
family and the home secretary will be
aware
that the whole nation was upset
by the images of women who had come
to a peaceful vigil
about violence to women
and who found themselves wrestled to the
ground
and handcuffed by police officers
is the home secretary aware
that the metropolitan police's statement
which sought to justify what happened on
saturday
by talking about and i quote the
overriding need to protect
people's safety but issue where some
people
are puzzled with the idea that you can
make people safe
by manhandling them and handcuffing them
in relation to the policing bill which
the house
will be debating later she herself
has made it clear that this bill
is expressly designed to crack
down on peaceful protests
by groups like extinction rebellion and
black
lives matter she described black lives
matter peaceful process
as dreadful can she understand
why many people in this country believe
that giving the police even more
powers to crack down on peaceful
protests
can only lead to more
scenes like the distressing scenes
that the nation witnessed on saturday
at the vigil on clapham common home
secretary
thank you madam deputy speaker with
respect um to the right honourable
lady with regards first of all to the
events on saturday evening
um i would urge the honorable lady not
to be so judgmental until we actually
see the report
that comes from the inspector of
constabulary um the honourable lady
right honorable lady will have plenty of
opportunity to discuss
um protest and police powers through the
passage
of the bill but i would just like to say
this
in recent years we have seen a
significant change in protest
tactics which have led to disruption
which have also led to violence and
people's lives being endangered
so i look forward to the debates with
the honourable lady on this particular
point
later on but she's absolutely wrong in
her characterization of the measures
that we are introducing
before i call the next week could i um
just say that i'm very keen to make sure
we get everybody um in in
in this important statement so um
if i could ask colleagues to be fairly
brief with their
questions and obviously the answers as
well so graham brady
try my best madam deputy speaker the
home secretary has
rightly said that the right to protest
is a cornerstone
of our democracy but as she also said
this house on the 6th of january voted
swinging powers
to control uh protests for the period of
the coronavirus restrictions
can i ask her to work with concerned
members across the house
to make sure that the legislation that
we're about to pass
protects that right of peaceful protest
uh and only stops serious disruption
well my right humble friend is
absolutely right and i thank him for his
question
i will continue to always engage with
colleagues or colleagues on this
it's a really important point and i know
how hard it has been for many colleagues
in this house
looking at the regulations implications
of those regulations and the
restrictions that they have brought in
and of course
this would also be subject a bit to
debate in the house going forward
harriet harman um thank you madam deputy
speaker
and i would like to pay my deepest
sympathy in respects to the
family of sarah average and her many
dismayed and grieving friends
are welcoming the re i welcome the
reopening of the violence against women
and girls statements
survey consultation um it's evident that
the home secretary recognizes the
genuine
and justified strength of feeling about
women's safety
that lay behind the vigil on clapham
commons so surely it was just wrong of
the metropolitan commissioner
to refuse to reach agreement with the
organizers
to find a way so the vigil could go
ahead
but to do so safely does she agree with
the joint committee on human rights that
the law on protest
during this covet pandemic needs
clarifying
so that protests can go ahead but do so
safely
the joint committee on human rights has
drafted regulations which will be
published
with our report later this week will she
undertake to consider them seriously
with a view to laying them
before the house secretary well i thank
um
the right honourable lady for her
comments and look
i think everybody across this house you
know has expressed
shock grief and obviously concern
about the images from saturday evening
no dispute there whatsoever i will of
course look at the report when it is
published
i'd be more than happy to have
discussions with colleagues about the
report as well
we are in a pandemic and this has been a
very very difficult period it's been
difficult for the police as well i'm the
first to acknowledge that
we've asked the police to do
unprecedented things they have
unprecedented powers
throughout this pandemic based on the
need to protect public health
one would hope now that collectively
with the incredible work of the vaccine
roll out and you know as we ensure that
that carries on smoothly
as we move through the prime minister's
roadmap and the plan of easement
that we can work together to absolutely
yes live with coronavirus but do things
differently
we now go to faye jones
thank you madam deputy speaker and i
joined colleagues across the house
in sending my heartfelt condolences to
sarah everard's loved ones
i'm shocked at the way in which saturday
night's vigil was policed
the situation demanded sensitivity and
compassion something which was evidently
lacking
but i'm also shocked that what started
as a peaceful and important vigil
turned into a protest with photographs
showing a c a
b signs which stands for all cops are
bastards
madam deputy speaker i'm concerned that
a young woman's murder could be hijacked
by those who would seek to defund the
police
and destabilize our society making it
even harder for women to come forward
and report assaults
with the home secretary confirmed that
nothing will deter the government
from delivering stronger legislation to
protect women and girls from harm
10 seconds my own friend is absolutely
right and i thank her for her points
that she has made
our apologies for the language you may
have heard in the last
few minutes in these exchanges in the
house of commons we're going to return
now to pretty patel
and to ensure that they are safeguarded
in the right way
but at the same time she's made a very
very important point that a
peaceful visual vigil on saturday
turned into some pretty ugly scenes so
we'll wait for the report
and there is no question that where
there are lessons to be learned they
will be learned
and of course where individuals were
acting
inappropriately in the way in which she
has said obviously that'll be subject to
some consideration too
we now go to rosie duffield
thank you madam deputy speaker firstly
i'd like to put on record
my thanks to kent police for their
incredibly difficult work in the ongoing
investigation
into the tragic death of sarah everard
in order to seriously tackle violence
against women and girls it's vital to
put women at the heart of legislation
however in today's policing bill women
are not even
mentioned with that in mind and with
rape convictions being a
shocking all-time low how will the home
secretary ensure that women can come
forward with confidence
that they will be believed and that they
will receive
justice secretary thank you mr speaker
um if i may i'd just also like to give
my thanks to kent police
for all the work that they have been
doing in conjunction with the
metropolitan police
in the investigation associated with the
sarah everard case this has been a very
very difficult time across policing
there's no doubt about that
madam deputy speaker i'm not going to
come back in details um
to the point because i have covered many
already in my statement
but i speak with conviction in my
determination
as does every member of this government
when it comes to safeguarding women and
also our strategies
and approach to violence against women
and girls and as i've repeatedly said
madame jesse speaker i would welcome all
members to join us
in a cross-party effort to do much more
to give women and girls the confidence
to come forward
so charles walker thank you madam deputy
speaker madam deputy speaker
this house criminalized the freedom of
protest
this house us not damn cressida not the
metropolitan police
we did we criminalized the freedom to
protest collectively
we are up to our eyeballs in this does
the home secretary my right honourable
friend
agree with me that now is the time to
decriminalize
freedom of protest not tomorrow not next
week
but this afternoon this evening let's
get people
back on the streets let's allow people
to get things off their chest
again protest is a safety valve
home secretary deputy speaker i
understand entirely the sentiment that
my
right honourable friend um has um
emphasized and echoed this afternoon
um the prime minister has laid down a
road map and i appreciate that the
honourable white honorable gentleman
would love me to say right now
let's just do this and change things
immediately
there is a road map that has been laid
out we are still in a pandemic
and we are following with the guidance
that has been put in place
and obviously this will be subject to
debate over the next week or so
and i'm more than happy to continue to
discuss this with my colleagues
uh we now go to vicki foxcroft
thank you madam deputy speaker peaceful
assembly must be an
absolute right in this country and the
actions of the police on saturday were
deeply troubling
and i'd like to highlight the use of
kettling in particular
many disabled people and disabled
people's organizations
have long raised concerns about the use
of this controversial
crowd control tactic which in the past
has been used for up to 10
hours with serious potential health
implications
what does the home secretary have to say
to the many disabled people
who fear this disproportionate policy
secretary thank you madam deputy speaker
um deputy speaker
in response to the honourable ladies
question around
operational tactics which obviously
catalin
is based upon a situation and a police
assessment
around a protest or an event that might
take place
that is obviously something that the
police themselves make a decision on and
judgments on in terms of the tactics
that they use
as part of their operations she's also
though raised an important point about
people with disability disabled people
should they wish to express
themselves part join protests and
participation
and of course their needs can be met
through protests and the way in which
they express themselves by working with
the police
and many of the organisation organizers
that talk to the police around the
types of people the groups um and the
type of characteristics of the
individuals that are coming out to
protest as well
so this isn't just about you know a
one-size-fits-all approach she will be
well aware as to the approach that the
police take when it comes to
organizations and engaging with
organizers over protests
thank you we now go to laura faris
speaker and i'd like to put on record my
sympathies to the family
and partner of sarah everard um
thank i thank my right-on-board friend
for her statement in the last
few months i've been working with our
streets now on the issue
of public street harassment vile
and explicit language that is aimed at
women with the purpose of degrading them
and they are often
children school girls i look forward to
my writing of all friends strategy later
this year but would she also consider as
part of that
bringing forward legislation that might
address this issue
well my friend has raised an important
point in fact i've met
many young girls school girls in fact
who are part of that campaign
we will consider all options as part of
the war strategy
we now go to allison thulis
thank you madam deputy speaker on sunday
i shed a tear along with so many other
women at the gates of queen's park where
ribbons and tributes had been
left in memory of sarah everard and for
moira jones who was raped and murdered
there in 2008
and for all women who've experienced
abuse at the hands of men
so can i ask what the home secretary is
going to do to change the toxic culture
that we have
which diminishes and minimizes women's
experience and to challenge this whole
spectrum of men's behavior
so that my daughter and all young women
can grow up without living their lives
in fear
home secretary the other lady has an
opportunity as well to join us
and she's heard me speak today mad and
deputy speakers all colleagues have
about the need to contribute to our vog
strategy this isn't about the work of
one individual this is about
what we do collectively together in
terms of cultural norms and changing
behaviors
we all have a role to play and i urge
her to join us in that effort
we now go to heather wheeler
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
can i thank my right honourable friend
for a statement
and extend my heartfelt condolences to
sarah everard's family at this time
does my righteous friend agree with me
and my south derbyshire constituents
that it is frankly absurd for the party
opposite to in the same breadth call for
tougher
sentences against rapists whilst also
opposing this bill
which delivers exactly this well my
interference has summed it up perfectly
and i completely agree with the
sentiment that she's just expressed
we now go to tonya antoniazi
thank you madam deputy speaker last week
on the armed forces bill committee we
heard about prosecuting crimes including
reid through the military courts
one statement stood out to me where it
was said i was service people are
thoroughly good people
but they drink too much something goes
wrong and they end up in court
now what discussions has her department
had around this attitude
towards victims of male violence and
does this reflect a general attitude to
women that we saw on saturday on clapham
common home secretary well
i think first of all no it does not
reflect a general attitude to women and
no one should
um pre-judge or just make assumptions of
that nature
in terms of she's made a very important
point though in terms of the armed
forces work and
the the work that's taking place across
both our departments in fact
and our minister for safeguarding um has
done extensive work
on this particular issue with our
colleagues in the ministry of defense
and of course that will continue
you now go to caroline noakes
thank you madam deputy speaker can i
express my condolences to sarah
everard's friends
and family and thank the home secretary
for reopening the vault consultation
and for requesting the lessons learned
review into saturday night's
policing she has shown that she has
determined there will be action
not just words 78 000 responses
so far is absolutely enormous these are
women who do not have confidence in the
system at present
and we desperately need to instill
confidence for them
that will take an enormous effort in
shifting cultures
in coming together and working
collectively to make sure we achieve
that aim
but can my right honourable friend
assure me that those women
are going to have their voices heard in
the justice task force
which looks suspiciously like an
all-male room
home secretary thank you madam deputy
speaker i thank my
um right honourable friend for her her
points and obviously
the importance and significance of the
vorg consultation
in fact that's been reopened um let me
give her assurance that the crime and
justice task force is not a
male show at all um both myself
i'm i i am obviously as part of part of
that
as is the safeguarding minister and
there are many
other agencies and parties that are
involved in that
including the first female metropolitan
police commissioner as well so there are
a range of voices
and again i would urge people from being
too judgmental
that all the work that takes place in
government is just by men
because it is not again just a reminder
to colleagues that we do need to be
quite
um brief in our questions if we're going
to be able to get everybody in which
i do want to do i'm sure the way will be
led by kim johnson
thank you madam deputy speaker and i'd
like to add my thoughts and condolences
to the families of sarah
everard bieber henry and nicole smallman
and all women who have died finally
just the home secretary agree with me
that if you're black
disabled or a trans woman you are
disproportionately more likely
to be a victim of violence this is not
emphasized in the crime sentencing
and courts bill and what steps is she
taking to rectify this
thank you madam deputy speaker home
secretary honourable lady
we want to prevent anybody we want to
prevent anyone from becoming a victim of
crime
and it is not just our conviction
determination but it should be our
collective imperative
to make sure that no one becomes a
victim
and particularly anybody from the groups
that she has just referred to
we now go to maria miller
can i also send my deepest sympathy to
the family and friends of sarah everard
and
echo comments made uh with regards to
the events of saturday evening
because nobody should have to feel
threatened when streets
when on our streets the best way to
prevent violence against women and girls
is to tackle the root causes of that
violence
new government researchers identified
viewing pornography particularly violent
pornography
as an influential factor in harmful
sexual behavior towards women and girls
what would my right honourable friend be
doing to reflect that finding in new
government policy
secretary well my right-hand friend has
in fact made a very very powerful and
important point
about the behavioural aspects and the
links to pornography
and i know it's an issue that she
herself has been focused on i'd very
much like to discuss this with her
further
as part of our work to protect women
and girls um from violence now go to
vera hob house thank you madam
deputy speaker my heart goes out to
sarah avraham's family and friends
during this
horrific horrific time madame deputy
speaker a year ago
on international women's day i tabled a
private member's bill making my surgery
a hate crime in light of the recent
horrific events and the continuous
failure to prevent
women and girls from violence will the
government now commit
to adopt my bill to end some of the
injustices
that continue
speaker the honorable lady will know
that the law commission
is looking at this area and in fact
their consultation closed in december
so i absolutely will work with the house
and report back on this whole area um
and continue to work with the minister
for safeguarding on the city
we now go to suzanne webb
the home secretary pretty patel there
who's given a statement to the house of
commons
announcing an independent review to be
carried out into the met police's
handling of
the vigil at clapham common on saturday
night following
the death of sarah everard
she reiterated the phrase that so many
have
uh said since the death of sarah everard
she was just
walking home and said that since
reopening their consultation on violence
against women and girls on friday
there have been 78 000 responses
that is up from 18 000 over the 10-week
period
of the initial consultation such is the
strength of feeling
and the reaction to the death of sarah
everard
let's bring in our correspondent chief
political correspondent john craig who
was listening in
to the exchanges many questions about
the
metropolitan police handling of this
also about the upcoming debate over the
police crime sentencing
and courts bill and some on the tory
back benches concerned about
coronavirus regulations and the part
they may have played john
yes they were the lock down skeptics the
sort of people you'd expect to
say those things there was sir charles
walker uh
saying that we passed these uh laws uh
criminalizing uh public
protest uh there were complaints
actually on
from those mps there was philip davis
making some suggestions about
more closed circuit tv to protect women
and so on
uh sir graham brady however on the labor
side
in particular there was strong criticism
of the police action from the likes of
diane abbott and harriet harmon there
was only it was only ed
davey the liberal democrat leader who
directly called for the resignation of
uh cressida dick the met commissioner
of course she should resign he said he
was immediately slapped down by ian
duncan smith
former conservative leader who said that
he'd been contacted by a female officer
who had
been been manhandled he said
and uh and uh threatened during the
debate and there was another
conservative mp
uh faye jones from brecken and radner in
wales
who talked about the possibility of the
vigil being hijacked
by people who she said wanted to defund
the police
so a lot of controversy as you say ahead
of that bill
later on which is being debated okay
john craig
there in westminster for us thank you
lots more on that coming up in the next
hour here
on sky news with news out with mark
austin